make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing our series on MCU
villains which is to say taking villains
and rolling them over in the MCU and
honestly we should just call it like MCU
characters so we'll probably start
getting into heroes too in this video I
want to be a little bit dangerous and I
want to talk about how to put Moon
Knight in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but to do it as a villain in the comics
munites not really a villain he's kind
of an antihero the problem is were the
exception of Jeff Lemire nobody ever
really did anything with Moon Knight
that was stellar right I mean nobody
ever really like focused on on any of
the major issues that he dealt with but
the origin of Moon Knight deals with the
idea that there was simply a guy named
Mark Spectre right and he worked for
like the CIA he was a former boxer a
former US Marine and he was on an
expedition working with a guy by the
name of Peter al rain and his daughter
Marlene kind of a fun fact on the way
there they were listening to audible yes
this is a sponsored video sponsored by
audible so with audible every month you
get one free audiobook and two free
audible originals from an ever-changing
list one of my favorites is actually
World War Z by Max Brooks if you guys
never listen to it is actually pretty
solid it's basically this book that
deals with like the history of the
zombie war but told from different
people's perspectives it's it's pretty
solid
but audible is pretty great if you're on
the go right so like you're going to the
beach or you're going hiking or you're
going road-tripping I like it when I'm
driving to the mountains but go to
audible.com slash Commons explain or
text your code college explain to five
hundred five hundred to get started
Amazon Prime members can actually get
audible for four ninety-five a month for
the first three months we're just like
getting three months for the price of
one and after that it's only 14.95 a
month and this offer ends on July 31st
of 2019 so make sure you guys go to
audible.com slash commerce explained or
text commerce explain to five hundred
five hundred to get started today
but getting back in the moon night the
way the story played out is that with
you working alongside dr. alrey really
Peter in Marlene let's go ahead and call
him that
a working alongside Peter and Marlene
they had discovered these this temple of
source that was made and worshiped to
the the Egyptian god conch you now the
issue with this was that around that
time they were all ambushed by a guy
named wild Bushman right now Bushmen
being an opportunist either to his
advantage and then of course he and Mark
Specter got into a fight and that led to
March Spectre being defeated and
actually left for dead and so following
that the worshipers of khonshu came
along and they brought more expect her
to the statue of khonshu which in turn
uh really with marc spector more or less
dying it had a kind of vision of sorts
now this is where things get kind of
murky
right because uh with this vision
khonshu basically says I'll give you a
second chance at life all you have to do
is be my avatar on earth and then of
course marc spector says yes and he goes
forward Antony to become a superhero and
so once he travels back wheeler travels
back to the US what he does is he takes
all the money that he made as a
mercenary and he interned like channels
that really kind of funneled it into
huge investments and builds himself a
fortune and then takes on the moniker of
a millionaire named Steve grant but in
order to be a superhero and to be on the
ground level he forms the identity of a
guy named Jake Lockley who's a cab
driver now the issue with this is what
it does is it actually kind of spins and
sends him into a tailspin of like
schizophrenia and that's one of the
reasons why he's so cool right it's one
of the things that like writers never
really seem to focus on they kind of
focus on him as like a character who's
just there he had his own solo run like
for a while he's never really been able
to hold it very long it's just kind of
been like this run and then this run and
then this run and then this run it's not
ongoing right it's like uncanny x-men or
Iron Man where it spans like four
hundred issues or anything like that
there's always an effort by Marvel to
launches on solo series his core fan
base reads that nobody else does but
that fan base isn't big enough to
maintain you know a solo run and so
Marvel ends up canceling it but if the
Marvel Cinematic Universe does it right
what you're gonna end up getting is this
this guy um who's very Batman esque
right and like midnight fans hate it
when you compare him to Batman but I
mean come on like anybody with eyesight
can tell like he's basically a pastiche
of Batman by Batman has patches Malone
Moon Knight has Jake Lockley Batman's
Bruce Wayne like Moon Knight is Steve
grant like it's obvious you know and in
terms of the character being a play on
Batman but the idea is that if he was
thrown into the MCU and he was done well
it would say a few things one apparently
Marvel like the Marvel Cinematic
Universe can make a better Batman the
Warner Brothers which are gonna suck and
two he would go into this idea that they
could develop a character beyond what
we've seen so far right because the
Marvel Cinematic Universe for the most
part is largely upbeat right I mean like
for the most part all the movies are
pretty upbeat
there's some serious movies but there's
not really any like dark movies right
there's there's no movies out there that
deal with things like like the way
Legion does on FX or anything like that
and that's not a bad thing but in order
for the MT MCU to really like thrive and
survive well beyond these last 10 years
you're gonna kind of need a more dynamic
in the more diverse portrayal of heroes
as they exist in in like in Marvel
Comics carried over to film form and so
if you take a character like Moon Knight
and you basically say that by virtue of
all these personalities that Marc
Spector has essentially developed either
skids afraid
or multiple personality disorder he
doesn't really know which ones is actual
personality which one's real then like
it creates a whole new set of events
right because the schizophrenia comes
into play in the question of did khonshu
actually appear to him is he is he
actually an avatar of khonshu on earth
that's one of the things that was
addressed during Jeff Lemire is run like
did it really happened or is he just a
crazy guy and then the multiple
personality comes and comes into play
and which one was actually the PERT the
person who was approached by khonshu if
that actually happened was it mark
Spector was it Jake Lockley was it Steve
grant which one was it and so it really
kind of gets cool and murky when it when
it comes to these waters and when you
take that idea and you throw it into the
MCU you can portray him as a villain and
you can basically say this is a guy who
by virtue of his own past experiences or
what-have-you
believes that he's the avatar of khonshu
and going forward he's not really a
villain I guess straight up so much is
like an antihero
but he's extreme where the Avengers are
like hey look we have to stop this guy
and then take him to the cops
like munites fine with killing them and
so the result is that you end up having
incoming that come into conflict
directly with like any of the Avengers
now in my mind I actually think Moon
Knight would make a better villain for
like daredevil or somebody like that but
they would have to roll daredevil over
into the movies which by the way I think
it's high time that we take daredevil
like Matt Murdock like we take him from
from from what used to be the Netflix
series it's been canceled now but from
the Netflix series and actually give him
his own movie because by god like he's
earned it man liked you the Netflix do
daredevil was bought like like far and
away the best of the series on Netflix
Punisher was cool well I'll give it to
daredevil he needs to be in his own
movie but if they were to give daredevil
a movie and then they were to give him a
villain
give him moon night it'd be a great way
to introduce the character in right
because people are already gonna be
hyped about a daredevil film starring
Charlie Cox and then they're gonna be
hired about the possibility of like Moon
Knight being thrown in which even if
they don't really know his origin they
know of him and I think that's popular
enough popularity to be able to like
carry him through and the very least get
people's butts into the seats and to see
the film if not word-of-mouth will take
care of all that if it's done correctly
but you you literally through all the
all these things in this is a guy with
schizophrenia possible multiple
personality disorder and then the intern
is trying to become a hero it's it seems
like a crazy guy and then like what you
can kind of do you can either answer the
film you can kind of in the movie with
an absolute answer right and sake yes he
was visited by khonshu yes marc spector
is there is the actual personality yes
he's a little bit lost in himself and
then almost took a page out of like who
is the century from Brian Michael Bendis
as New Avengers run and have somebody
sit down with with with Marc Spector
with Moon Knight and basically go
through and kind of permeate through all
the knots
and say here is who you actually are you
are actually a marc spector that's your
actual name you wore a mercenary you
were working for the CIA you were a US
Marine and you were left for dead in the
desert and you were visited by khonshu
that's a lot of worse but again it can
be done exceedingly well and it could be
done really like it could be super cool
because what you would have is this
movie with a complex and dynamic
character that doesn't take three movies
in order to really develop into build
but you have this complex and dynamic
character who really toys with the first
instance of an antihero in the films
right because in the movies it's hero
and villain and that's it it's like the
Silver Age of comics in the 1960s
there's a good guys and the bad guys and
there's no there's no difficulty in
understanding which is which and Netflix
it gets a little more hairy when you're
talking about Jessica Jones versus Luke
Cage versus daredevil versus Danny Rand
and especially the Punisher but with
regards to the film's is a lot more
clear-cut you could introduce an element
in there and say hey here's a good guy
who sometimes duds does bad things it'd
be a great kind of precursor to like
looking at the movie developing Munna as
an antihero seeing what what sticks in
what doesn't stick and then apply that
to Wolverine right because I mean
Wolverine is an antihero he's like ve
antihero in comic books ah so it's a
great way to put the character in there
I think putting him in as a villain is
the best way to do it because then what
you can basically do is that once
everything's all sorted out and it's all
said and done and assuming for example
that they come back and they say yes
he's like that whole stuff about khonshu
is true then he does become a hero and
that's that right he's just kind of kind
of in there and he's like alright cool
he goes on to become a good guy if they
decide not to take that route they still
have a way out of the whole thing right
they can say well no he's just a crazy
guy is really all he is moon dye fans
would be pissed but I think it would
actually be kind of cool right I mean I
think it'd be kind of interesting oh but
but literally just kind of pawn him up
and say yeah he's a villain and like now
he's going away and he's gonna be
putting like some some prison somewhere
which gives the opportunity for him to
come back possibly reform his ways and
they become a good guy again or become a
good guy going forward but there's a lot
of things you can do with him because
really we need somebody like Moon Knight
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe we need
someone who's one part crazy one part
antihero and all part interesting that
sounds like a 1980s film thing you know
one part zero 1 part crazy one parts
everything else I forgot what it was and
I said before but but nonetheless you
guys understand what I'm saying like the
notion of just a good hero like a good
guy and a bad guy wears thin really
really fast you need someone who toys
the line someone who's a little bit
murky somebody who's whose actions are a
little questionable but they're always
trying to do the right thing
we just sort of shrug our shoulders
sweep it under the rug you see oh yeah I
can let it slide you know that's kind of
what we need and in like the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and we don't have
that like we don't have that at the
moment and I think that Moon Knight is
an amazing way to bring that into the
MCU I mean in in my idea stardom at as a
villain turn him into a hero it's a
great way to kind of evolve and grow the
character and even if you don't do that
in one movie you can do it over the
course of several movies right it's kind
of like this background theme or here do
they face off against every once in a
while and somehow keeps managing to
escape whatever the case is like you
basically turn them into a guy that can
go on to become a future member of the
Avengers team so I think it'd be cool
and I think it'd be interesting but let
me know you guys think down in the
comments section if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the
robb core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you